hello there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to watch House of
the Dragon episode 8 today John how are
you I'm just giddy with Glee you you sir
how's Greg I'm feeling good team Allison
right guys oh yeah everyone in the
comments keeps chanting it team team
Allison put on that green light that's
what we're all talking about here at the
reject nation is how we're all back in
teamhouse that's right dude you know I
hope renira dies this episode of the UK
audience picks up on sarcasm ladies and
gentlemen leave a like that would be
very much appreciated breathe fire onto
that subscribe button to get notified
when our reaction for the next episode
is up also full interaction watch along
through sync up with your own copy for
hotd available for a super sexy rejects
over at our Patron page and cover a
bunch of shows over there exclusively
for super sexy rejects lastly the team
of prepper thank you guys for the hustle
and bustle for helping us at the stuff
down let's get into action
[Music]
my God
and yet I have seen Blood Fever overcome
men half his age I will not suffer the
talk of crows in my house payment wow
drift Mark Is Mine by All rights and one
I should like your support I
iron
from the queen I don't want Corliss to
die I like Corliss
[Music]
wow what a shot
yes
oh he's got his he had his sneaking robe
on
he looks so happy
come ruin his good mood he means to cool
into question
Venom spread so far those vipers rule in
my father's name
father
it's got to be like a pile of sand now
yeah just like uh
he's become one with like a wall
it's a petrified tree root with a crown
on it
Guillermo del Toro creature
Amato has arisen that requires your
attention
it is you need to wait America Grace
it's about the prince
there's been a delicate situation in his
Apartments
what did he do
oh
see the cobwebs on it
wow
that's poor guy
still have like Alzheimer's maybe it
seems like
the sea snake has taken a grave wound in
battle in Step stones
the big call is for Lauren's successor
someone we wish to introduce you to
such great like underlying nuances in
the scene
two performances
this is agon
oh God
and this is viserys
that that is his name
Fit For A King
hi
oh
they're like keeping him sick I was just
about to ask that yeah it was fetching a
princess wine and I put it on his table
when I turned
I didn't see him
I asked him to stop you guys
[Music]
God
wow
what would I worry about
the butt that's what others might
believe
you're alone with the prince were you
not
yes
and no one else thought to happen
between the two of you oh Jesus
Jesus you might think you're trying to
massage the prince or worse
that you're the sort of girl that might
have enticed him in the first place
you know what happens to girls like that
hey how was that dream about anything
another one to anyone oh
it's supposed to be certain
it's at the same drink they gave renera
yeah I think so at least they're just
straight up poisoned yeah I was like I
hope it's the plan BT
what is it what is it
what is it what is it that's all you can
save yourself there's something happened
oh my God it's so Fury
shame on your wife on me
how can you keep carrying on like
there's a special on a day like today
why what is it today
nothing's changed the last six years
not not a King's Landing
I've done everything you've asked me to
and I try so
try so hard but it will never be enough
for you or father
have you seen Diana she's supposed to
dress the children
[Laughter]
oh
oh I guess that's our answer yeah
it's been so long since we were granted
the joy of your presence
oh still fresh
this day him paddled on look of the
poppy well the high Towers warmed us
through whenever if you would see him
without
lined with suffering suffering
I have no doubt it was an act of the
purest Mercy
which authority will sit in Judgment of
my son's claim on his own inheritance
held in this room
bye
mic drop
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
nephews
if you come to train he turned into
crisping Glover he did in a big place
like a whole other guy literally had to
question like is that crisping
I've always wanted to be on Game of
Thrones
to your son you may not believe it to be
true but I did
I did not order his death
nor was I complicit in it I swear this
to you
technically telling the truth I mean you
can let her know no you should get
yeah it would be a terrible idea back
Luke's claim and let us betray the
Lena's children to mine
a generous offer or adjustment
it does not matter
she's so good
walking with me all you like
but tomorrow the high Towers land their
first blue
they force you to your knees
and I'm a standalone
out you've got no allies The Song of Ice
and Fire
do you see it
it was our duty to hold the realm United
against a common firm
and naming the air you divided the Rock
another burden is a heavy one
especially when everyone hates you
it's defined your whole existence
Allison doesn't even sleep in the same
room no I guess not
I mean she probably only stops it on it
like once in a while now
God she really is becoming very
desperate huh
I want to have supper after
ah tonight
all of my family
to dine together
it's forever mission to resolve family
Trump tonight there will be peace
we'll fix it all tonight
whoa
damn that is insane makeup he is gaunt
as hand I speak with the king's voice on
this
and all other matters
living out as fantasy I Am Lord callis's
closest kin his own blood
the true and impeachable blood of house
valarian runs through my veins as it
does in my sons The Offspring of Lenor
valarian
he would not be so bold as to supplant
his rightful Heir now you only speak for
yourself and for your own ambition
you'll have chance to make your own
petition princess rhaenyra do serve him
in the courtesy of allowing kids to be
heard
oh my God what do you know of alarion
blood princess
I could cut my paint and show it to you
oh
I place the continuation of the survival
of my house and my line above all
that's a compelling ass argument I will
start by reminding the court that nearly
20 years ago in this favor
oh my God he lives my man
oh kingless series walking
the done hero King King
angels I'm the
first men
lord of the Seven Kingdoms and protector
it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
go stand up for her
come on viserys
you got one more good speech in you
[Music]
this poor guy it's just
breaks my heart how hard he tries this
is the saddest character in the entire
game of thrones universe
Phantom of the Opera
your grace
[Music]
come on Rocky
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
this messed up shows game
you guys are one sick family
but there's love
oh
[Music]
then he dies
I will die upon the throne
was having my husband's will that
driftmark
pass through soleno
to his trueborn son as a matter of fact
the princess rhaenyra has just informed
me of her desire to marry her sons Jason
Luke to Lord call us
proposal to which I heartily agree oh my
God
I have I reaffirm
princess Ceres of house valarian
there to drift mark
the driftwood's throne wow what a shot
what
is no true valerian
serious
is my trueborn grandson do you
know more than the Second Son of
driftmark
oh man
my house survived the doom and a
thousand tribulations besides
the account of this
head
hahaha
don't make the accusation our children
are bastards
is
oh man
huh
boy
oh damn love your tongue for that whoa
oh
wow whoa
tongue
Valerian steals Sharp
everyone needs to calm down guys
this is the most extreme chess game
I have the confidence Damon has
I want everyone to know that yep gonna
be the first to wave your sword
a little bit
holy crap that is gnarly
haunting it is your luck to look upon
the face of death
I feel bad for her she's had a really
shitty life man
damn and yet she maintains such
composure it's insane
now that this happened Laura Corliss has
to pull through
there's some
amazing composition in this shot in this
episode unlike the other episodes
terribly shot episodes shaky cam can't
see any of the production values too
dark
I like the nighttime episode
how the ACT is done I assume
at least in principle but
God
the faces most dear to me in all the
world you've grown so distant from each
other
in years past
wow
oh my God that's incredible I wish you'd
see me
I am who may not it seems
walk for much longer among you
your feelings in our hearts
I'm trying man
I wish to raise my cup to her grace the
queen
I must admit that no one has stood more
loyally by his side than his Good Wife
she has tended to him with
a failing devotion
love
honor and for that she has my gratitude
fair enough we have more in common than
we
sometimes allow
I raise my cup to you
guys
why can't you all just get along you'll
make a fine Queen
wow
oh I regret the disappointment here soon
to suffer
never wish to know what it is to be well
satisfied all you have to do is ask
weary continuity there
oh damn he was ready
ah
how
to Prince aegon and
Prince aymond we have not
seen each other in years but I have fond
memories of our shared youth yeah really
I hope we may not be friends and allies
do you and your family's good health
dear uncles
there's a bit of a rocky road up until
now you don't always see eye to eye to
you as well
[Laughter]
oh geez
you know what it's like to be satisfied
on the floor
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
I don't trust any good things that
happen
no something Terrible's gonna go down
[Music]
he's gonna pass
wow
[Music]
oh
[Music]
use the last of his strength to try to
do a loving Act
[Music]
ah the big
wow
final tribute
to these three
strong boy I dare you to say that again
why
it was only a compliment
do you not think Yourself Strong
what are you guys doing
for these people I was merely expressing
how proud I am of my family mother
I invented this game
it's best I think if we go back to
Dragonstone
oh they're really friendly
oh what snap
what are you doing man
I wanted for spies yeah
Prince
open second
take him back
it's the cold
wow
this is you
you are
you are wow
I understand Mikey
's on the fire and ice
foreign
goddamn
got [ __ ] to talk about
oh
heaviest family reunion in the realm
all right so I think what happened here
at the very end and please
feel free to clear up without possibly
spoiling the future of the show I
believe he was taught he thought he was
talking to rhenera because she asked him
earlier
um when he when she was in bed yeah
about the song of ice and asking if he
believes it's true yeah and he's saying
you want to know if it's true so and and
in that scene he thought Allison came to
him yeah so I think he's just getting
confused so it's like kind of a flip
root here and then because because
Allison is not supposed to know about
the prince that was promised that is a
secret thing that's passed on in the in
the blade of that can only be to the a
Targaryen or one who inherits I believe
that's that's how the rules go right
um what are the rules of the Zora high
so I but I believe that's what that's
what it is so and it was aegon the
Conqueror who had the prophecy yes and I
think she's getting confused out of the
center right now yeah
yeah and I and I feel like Allison is
now interpreting it to mean a different
thing yeah because I don't because
Allison shouldn't know about that no and
because that's why she was very confused
and she was even sitting in the scene
right she was even saying like what the
hell are you talking about serious
so unite what now I feel like this
misunderstanding song of what is going
to lead to her not accepting how things
move forward now sure
and that she thinks that for Sarah's I
could be way off
but what I do know is Allison shouldn't
know about that
and so I feel like she's thinking that
viserys is saying that aegon's the one
and that's and that's also who Ellison
is the one Allison's always been telling
aegon you were supposed to be the
rightful error okay you're supposed to
be the one who actually go up there
and this is coming off of the heels of
Allison accepting that rhaenery could be
Queen
and now I think it's all going to kind
of backfire undo all of this yeah yeah
oh
that's that's happening I'm pretty sure
that's what's going on yeah because I
was like why would he be talking to her
about that and then I I played it back a
tiny bit and he said I didn't catch it
at first but he said you wanted to know
and I was like oh okay yeah I definitely
think he's talking to an Era oh
damn what what an uneasy Grim note to
end on yeah but it's already a stark
that's the prince of his promise don't
forget yeah it's true it's like she's
the one who used to play
King like that upset people well I think
the
um if I'm not mistaken that that print
because that's it's with the whole Lord
of Light Pro um religious system
whatever you want to call it uh revolves
around is this prophecy and
I think Prince is I don't think it was
gender specific because from Valerian
okay
heavy spoilers did it like a really
great Paul they did a great you guys
know better
he did he did a great video just the
other day
um going over
um going over the children's one is
fresh in my mind and so yeah would be
great if we just watch that right now
and take a break yeah with all that
information yeah yeah it's a great it's
a great video it is it's actually a
really wonderful Theory video that could
help explain why Arya was the one to
ultimately take down the night King okay
based off of an encounter that happened
in the last episode when she did Slash
um not Danny uh renera so it's a really
it's a really really well constructed
video but yeah uh there's nothing no no
this is covered in that video so I'm
like oh wow this is not it's totally
unexpected of me uh but yeah
let's see what the future holds but I
feel like this this ending scene
obviously to end on it has to have some
massive implications of Direction
because they're like there's no way of
the freaking Allison to Renee she's
gonna be like this will be buzzing away
episode eight things are gonna be just
fine and everyone's gonna accept what's
going on yeah yeah so shouts out to the
king of the hotd breakdowns right now
um
so now let's backtrack let's go over the
episode because this was a wonderful
episode uh again they knocked it out of
the park with introducing I already
forgot his name it's it's not I think
there's some baymen or something yeah
something like that but for a second he
also named Eamon
wouldn't hurt George RR Martin
just change it up a little bit oh yeah
change it up just a tiny bit more please
and Elena's daughter is named after her
I think so like you know so much
crossover yeah some of the names get
confusing but like introducing him
and then seeing what the repercussions
were of of what the debate would become
and then what It ultimately culminated
into and I don't know I thought viserys
died like three times and so maybe he's
still alive
I feel like I feel like's gonna outlive
that baby deserves at this point that's
the subversion of this show the original
Game of Thrones series was like we're
gonna kill all kinds of characters you
wouldn't expect and this show is just
we're gonna keep this one guy alive way
longer than you could ever expect it's
gonna evolve into the future it's gonna
evolve into the Futurama yes
maesters are just gonna wheel him in on
a tray full of milk of the poppy like
let him die just love dogs
400 years old
everyone he can't speak anymore he just
blinks with his one good eye
yeah
if this is a send-off like what a
performance it looks like he's it sure
comes across them but I just don't know
and I feel like it would be an opportune
time to have him be dead or or maybe
they'll make him like uh brain dead but
like yeah because now he can't clarify
any of this and I feel like dramatically
that will be the barrier and that will
be the kind of the thing that will allow
him to slip off this coil is like oh
there's a there's a way that you can uh
you know after you've said the thing to
the wrong person that you shouldn't say
you know there's no way you can you know
try and smooth this over again yeah you
know and especially with no means to
clarify I feel like that will light the
Powder Keg that has been brewing this
whole season I mean all he's been trying
to do and it's and if I if I am to
interpret what just happened here at the
very end
uh that he is indeed dead is with his
pacifistic ways has been just trying to
keep the peace and try to keep everyone
back in like everyone it's all family
and blood and whatever and
everyone here just really looks like the
politics of it all and he's and as king
he's the only one who's like
we can't forget
so a
H
what have you got you were my favorite
people in the world here with me tonight
put down your penny difference like he's
using his last moments to try to just
end all quarrels um amidst inside this
and like that moment when he showed up
in the middle of because I was like
let's face it Raymond I think it's his
name he was winning
you know as much as I love Rainier I'm
like I think this guy I easily has to
claim to drift please give it to this
guy
well I mean I thought again even
coreless was like people don't remember
blood they remember names and and the
last episode I think yeah yeah and it's
a compelling debate and as much as at
the you know as much as I appreciate
what he's saying and in some ways I
could you know kind of get on board with
that in other ways I'm like well given I
don't know it's fascinating to watch as
people dance on ceremony and all the
this show makes a really great display
and it exists in every government
Society culture but yeah like the ways
in which people ignore the truth in
favor of the structures we have set in
place and agree upon and yeah that whole
thing about blood versus it's like I I
felt so much for what Corliss was saying
even in rhenice's uh you know protest at
that point about yeah it's the name that
counts I will be remembered if my name
continues but I don't know I mean there
is something fundamental and Elemental
about blood and I feel like that's one
of those things that will come down like
I bet every viewer probably agrees
differently and here yeah like I thought
he made a very compelling argument and
there was only one who's compelling
argument was oh
so yeah I think that uh it was it's just
because you don't want necessarily
narrow to lose but you know especially
when it cuts back to rainey's uh when
she's looking at vaman's
half decapitated uh that I'm like oh man
I feel so bad for her I was so caught up
in the moment yeah and then even when he
shows up you know like she thought she
had a a chance to win and
then of course when visera shows up it's
like this is the defeat right there like
just the this oh this overwhelming
presence just takes over yeah the room
and of course the respect of hierarchy
and then the one guy who stands up to it
all with the truth
is cut down permanently silenced yeah he
could handle it better
a yes I mean he he knew he made his
choice you know clearly waited to say it
he clearly death in that moment yeah I
think is I think a lot of the
performances always have such great
underlying like weight behind what
they're all really communicating even
sometimes when you're just talking
politics
you could see like right away in that
first scene when uh renera and Damon
Unite with viserys
and how he's can't deal with the
uncomfortableness of this situation
whether he can't face his brother and
you can imagine all kinds of things
going on underneath Damon of I haven't
been there with my brother this is kind
of painful for me to see viserys like
this
and then renera is you know she went
there for political purpose and then
it's becoming about family now like I
don't know I want you to be our grandson
you know like there's so much other
other other things going on underneath
the surface and I think that's what's so
great about the writing packed with the
acting all in one yeah they all do that
so well even the whole debate scene too
so even when they're exchanging like
this show is like the master at
exchanging looks yeah so when they're
even when they're exchanging looks of
Raymond and Damon and then
they just both know you know like when
he eggs them on like just say it and
they're making a choice right there and
Raymond's like once I say this yeah I'm
dead especially yeah I've lost I I I've
watched systematically through this
conversation as my claim is being
ignored and written over so yeah like I
best best go out with honor but yeah
exactly in his perception he's dying
with honor yeah and so I think that's
kind of great and what an impact to make
in one episode sure hasn't been in any
other episodes right like I don't want
to call them being another episode not
prominently like maybe a little bit in
like a previous one or two but yeah like
this is definitely he is a character
this episode if he has shown up who's
the actor who plays of service
Patty considine fantastic yeah just uh
yeah
you're gonna start off very charismatic
and you have a lot of dialogue and we're
gonna let you like deteriorate over the
course of several episodes I bet that's
a fascinating Journey for an actor
because yeah I mean not only do you have
all these physical things happening to
you but you also have to really live a
harsh and long life on screen and then
yeah like check back in often years
later each time and he's always felt so
consistent and it always feels no matter
how long the jump this is like six years
of a jump but each time it you can feel
the in-between moments just due to the
richness of his performance and yeah in
an episode like this I imagine it's got
to be a lot on an actor because you know
like the scenes have to flow but you
don't want to be sitting there thinking
about you know how long am I pausing and
things like that instead of like to play
somebody in this completely sickly State
who is you know the you of breath and
speech is you know immense effort enough
like he really sells it in a way that's
not you know garish it's just really
natural and really affecting and he's so
like it's so sad it's weird it's like
you root for him but but like he's so
Earnest and sad yeah kind of always I
didn't even hear his display of strength
and his display of
um
you know Authority is sad is mournful
and uh yeah I don't know I like I I
can't think of I'm sure there are other
examples of it but but you know like
this the performance really does stand
out for that because yeah I mean he's
he's presented to you in this position
yeah like you said of being very
charismatic but you also have so many
reasons to suspect that that he's just
not made for this world and somehow he's
stuck it out but he's been punished so
heavily by the circumstances that it
feels like he's still lived this tragic
life even though he's technically you
know kind of won in a lot of ways yeah
you know oh a thousand percent yeah
and like the again all the yeah little
micro little expressions and to play
those through you know dementia and you
know ailing physical state and all that
stuff you know
Kudos well I love I love the
performances here from uh
Emma Darcy and Olivia Cook because
they they carry on the childhood that we
saw the the former actors portray
and that's something that always
resonates and especially in this episode
when they had a chance to kind of soften
up
and you know remind get a reminder of
you know we weren't always like this and
we were both kind of put in positions we
didn't ask for and here we are now yeah
you know deal with a lot of crap that
was thrusted us and a lot of things got
taken much more serious once we became
mothers you know
so to have these moments of just um it's
nice to give them some soft tender
moments before [ __ ] gets terrible again
because you know it's going to it I I
really love the harmony between the
writing and the acting because yeah like
the the writing is very rich and the
writing acknowledges the surface levels
and then the acting often has to convey
so much contrast underneath and it was
refreshing it was a fascinating scene
that dinner scene because it's like you
watch as the adults or at least you know
raniera and Allison and you know
viserys between them but you know you
you watch them yeah come past all the
rigmarole and all the [ __ ] into what
feels like a very genuine moment as
you're watching the kids do like the
Confederation the future Generations do
the complete inverse where it's like
well okay all everyone all the adults in
the rumor are telling us we got to do
this charades so we're gonna do it in
the least uh you know genuine way
possible and we're only going to drive
our wedges further how come Eamon turned
into like a 30 year old man
and he's I had to I had to do a double
take because they also like switched
physiques too whereas like aegon used to
be like the lanky long hair and now he's
you know a bit stockier and then yeah
Eamonn is just like he just yeah looks
like he's a completely different human
who emerged from the depths of some dark
pit you know and yeah he's just sitting
there just like I eyeballing everybody
but I also like how there seems to be a
tad bit of mirroring between
um him and Damon
mm-hmm it's I loved when they faced off
in that moment that brief moment like
even Damon seems to kind of get who he
is sure yeah yeah absolutely it even
smirks about it after Eamon walks away
yeah eamon's scary he's terrifying it
seems like since that night
it shows so good at the time I think
that's why the time jumps are so good
because a lot of times whatever the
ending point is of the show of the
episode
the time Jump is like and here is how
they all change because of that day yeah
I know yeah hearing the effects of that
down the line yeah like I think that's
just so wonderfully constructed because
you know you had a version of Eamon as a
child who was like a little bit cheapish
Yeah and then he was trying to find
strength and courage and was bullied and
the pig and God then when he got his
when he got vegar and he got his eye
slashed it's like and he had he had a
very specific
cold look at the very end that with the
little boy and I'm like Zach this adult
actor that's the same exact look you
know it just and it seems like he just
you can feel this sense that he is
fantasized about killing the one who
took his eye for so long yes every day
for these past six years and and to the
contrast again between that moment when
they have the confrontation over his eye
and he makes that realization of like
okay like how I behave here affects my
mother and could have serious you know
repercussions for her and now here he
seems to be headed in the opposite
direction and seems to be you know kind
of shedding you know he's a bit older
and he's gotta greed like [ __ ] so
you know yeah the the the lines of like
pageantry and and putting up faces or
precious thin especially with those two
like the two uh Eamonn and uh and aegon
like I love the aegon's just like
smirking it like he's he seems to have
just maintained the like I don't really
take much of anything seriously kind of
attitude and yeah eamon's just been
stewing and and probably is going to
become a very harsh and ruthless
character
kids became a lot more interesting this
episode yeah and I mean it's it's funny
it's it's a fascinating tap it's it's
again a testament to how well they're
able to weave all these Stakes because
you feel for renero's kids and you kind
of feel they they have obviously like an
underdogish quality because you know
it's a very thin line between the truth
and what protects them and then um you
know you have their claim on driftmark
which is actively kind of corroding and
erasing you know like a a a strong and
honorable family name and it's not
really their fault but also you know
they are in a kind of messed up
situation that they will then benefit
from and then you have uh aymond and
aegon who are
you know clearly aware of what should
have been like uh like all the yeah all
the colliding Stakes make everything so
tense but also like vital uh you know in
a way well I mean they killed that woman
and the other thing too is they killed
that woman at the beginning yeah yeah
and
and I forget her name
whoever the
former brothel yeah
um I completely forget her name but they
tease it at the end she had a spy and
there's like a maid and she was there to
deliver the drink yeah that would kill
her
and I'm like what that does I guess from
one perspective is that the queen
Allison is the one who
covered up something egregious
like it's like in this world like
it's not really surprising
that Allison would do that
I guess I'm I'm a little I wouldn't know
what I'm saying is I'm disconnected from
how the people
at King's Landing would respond
to that to learning of the information
of what the queen I don't know I guess
anything of but it's like any kind of
accusation is just a crime is treason
but yeah you I I I'm not sure what to
make of what's to become of that though
yeah yeah yeah yeah what what game is is
Damon's former flame running in keeping
track of all this and what what would be
the further repercussions of having that
information that
aegon
assaulted that woman and then
and then uh the queen covered it up
what would
I don't know in the current system you
know there are no repercussions nothing
gets out but but also I mean you can see
yeah yeah in an Empire that right now is
already you know a victim of infighting
and is you know
I forget the direct quote now but yeah
like you know A House Divided is you
know is weak and prone to fall and that
could easily like with all the stuff
surrounding rhaenyra and all the things
we saw the people in the streets saying
a few episodes back you know this could
easily taint and tarnish
yeah like I bet because we got aegon
with the prophecy slipped to Allison at
the end I imagined some kind of foisting
of his status will come out of that but
then if this information is also out
that you know this was covered up and
this is what he did then they can sow
those seeds of Deceit among the people
too so I don't know it all it all
translates into a mess for me yeah it'll
just become an even Messier even more
disgusting situation than it already is
and that's the thing like this episode
has that as that the show does but there
are constant big reminders of like oh
yeah this is not a world where the truth
sets anyone free
well
sure just keeps delivering guys hey
um what did you think about this episode
leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that Bell leave a like
and um
I'll send this with a patreon
aniso liver
now Anisa
the real rejects has been predominantly
men this entire time
but one day
we'll pass
I'll go
John will go I guess you would assume
maybe Coy's next in line to take over
then
but no we've decided that you will be
Queen of the reject Nation you will
inherit the real rejects Channel now I
know you don't film videos I know you
don't edit I know you don't know how to
make thumbnails you know you don't
understand SEO I know there's a lot you
don't understand
well that's why it's going to burn at
the ground in your hands
I'm not gonna lie I have zero faith that
you're going to be able to keep this
boat steady you are not the song of ice
and fire yet you will be blamed entirely
for the downfall of the real Rejects
and I think just as a woman
you should inherently have the strength
to uh take on unfair blame so Anisa you
are the perfect victim of the
circumstance
that we're dealing for you right now and
you have no say in the matter no say no
oh my God what and if anybody tries to
put koi on the the Iron Throne of the
region yeah
oh my God in fact we should just kill it
the next time he comes in just to make
sure
yeah
and we have to kill Sally he thinks he's
having G fuel when he comes here slowly
poisoning dude milk of the poppy on koi
sonisa
I would say I'm sorry but hey that's
just the world we live in
just get used to it
thank you for being here for like years
[Music]